I am excited to announce the establishment of an m m
I W G2S healing and Empowerment Endowment Fund.
The Manitoba government is investing $15 million
into the creation of an endowment fund
in partnership with the Winnipeg Foundation.
Our investment of $15 million will help support directly m m
I W G2S families.
This endowment fund will help support families
access healing and ceremony.
This endowment fund will also help support organizations
that are indigenous LED
and that are working on the front lines and working with m m
I W G families.
This endowment fund will accept donations from citizens directly
from Manitobans across Canada
that folks that want to invest will be able to make a donation.
We would like to see the endowment fund reach $50 million.
We will be ensuring that
we are seeking donations from corporate entities,
businesses,
the like, anybody that says that they believe in reconciliation,
that they're on the path of reconciliation,
action that, action that and invest in the endowment fund.
None of this would have been possible without the work of the families
and the courageousness of them.
And I remember when I first,
my sister first went missing and,
you know, how hard, um,
it was seeing family struggle,
watching families sit by the phone
waiting for a phone call or for that,
you know, that police officer to come and knock at that door
or like Minister Fontaine said,
excessively searching.
Like there's so many other things that families are Doing that,
they need so much more support.
So this endowment fund is gonna help support those families.
My story is very much the same as,
as many indigenous people across this country.
I think about my sister
and the injustice that was brought upon her during her life
and even after her death. I think about my sister's death 23 years ago
and how
this endowment fund would have helped to bring her body back home.
I am very happy to hear that there is this fund
that will help pave the way for that support
and for the ongoing initiatives that are transpiring across Canada.